what is black or white thinking a monkey
mind symptom a symptom of fear or
worry it's remember you know it's kind
of linear thinking it's it's either this
or it's
this and is that the same as either or
yeah I think it is it's the same thing
okay and what if some people say well
you know this linear thinking has served
me well like I know don't cross that
street don't do this do that I don't
want I don't want my I want to keep my
linear thinking I love that question
linear thinking is not bad and we don't
need to eradicate all linear thinking
for example a conclusion that is true is
when there's a red light you stop your
car at the red light let's not dismantle
that one let's keep that one for traffic
laws and safety but maybe there's a l a
linear thinking in an area of your life
where we need to examine it and see if
it's getting in the way of moving you
forward so again it's black or white
thinking to think all inar thinking is
bad and we need to dismantle it that's
not true there's no and it's not bad
it's just what it's kind of just
bringing our Focus to what is it that's
getting coming up for you or getting in
the way of you doing what you love to do
authentically and with ease you know we
spoke previously about author Julia
Cameron and we both said we we love her
writing from her book The Artist way she
writes judging your early artistic
efforts is artist abuse this happens in
many ways uh beginning work is measured
against the Masterwork of other artists
beginning work is exposed to premature
criticism shown to overly critical
friends Etc why do artists fall prey to
their own sort of negativity and
judgment it's the fear of success which
and the other side of the coin is the
fear of failure those are the same
fear it's what's going to happen when I
make it and what will happen if I don't
make it
so how we express that is through harsh
analysis of our work because we really
want to know if it's good enough and we
really want to know if I should really
be spending my time doing this we really
want to know am I going to fail at
this when I say we I mean like our brain
really wants the answers and so we try
and try and squeeze water out of a rock
by figuring it out by
overanalyzing that's just what we do
we're human what I always tell my
artists I say the process of creation
and the process of analysis are two
different processes make sure you keep
them
separate we cannot analyze as we create
I think that's what Julia Cameron speaks
to when she says we we we it's like
artist suicide we kill the dream before
we even get it out of
ourselves yeah another thing she said
that I've brought up many times before
an interviews was that it's easier to um
get sympathy and have people like you
when you're a blocked artist but if
you're actually doing really well that
might be more offputting to people and
so sometimes we take that on because we
want people to like us that's an
Exquisite question so yeah that's a huge
part of my own personal Manifesto and
application to this work I think it goes
into the struggling artist Motif and
this image we have um and that is
BS oh my gosh it's so limiting to stay
in our s uing because we think that is
our Muse yes we create excellent work
from our pain yes agreed I love Nirvana
just as much as the next person but the
point is that is
limiting that artistic suffering is a
myth in fact when we are able to thrive
and heal and make it through the woods
and I mean really do the work we
actually get to know a more authentic
version of ourself we we were not born
to suffer we experience suffering as a
human and it's an important and integral
part of our journey because trust me
once we are healed we are able to thrive
we are in much more access to a higher
level of creativity and Artistry and
expansion than we ever thought was
possible when we were keeping oursel in
suffering and it's okay if pain is our
Muse we are not going to get through
life painlessly there will always be
moments of pain and we don't have to
hold on to
it it's kind of like a grief process we
need to know when it's ready to be
integrated and when it's ready to be let
go and a really important part of that
is mastering the skill of
surrender and these are all skills that
we can learn and that what a coach what
I train my clients in doing expertly to
move away from this suffering and this
Motif and who cares how people see you
that's one of the first things it is not
about the external
audience the a we tell we the artists
tell the audience what to pay attention
to no matter what your art form is
you're telling them they are not telling
us and you think about like Adele if you
listen to her lyrics that's about
struggle if you think about let's say
Alanis morset Jagged Little Pill that
put her on the map that was so like you
would listen to lyrics and go oh wow
like you felt the raw like anger and
upset so you know she they're turning
these stories of whatever whether
they're based on real experiences or not
into their you know putting it into
their music and it resonated with people
worldwide yes and uh yeah same for it
could be men singing about the same
issue doesn't have to just be but um
right I guess um I meant more um that I
think sometimes people feel shame if
they're almost doing well as an artist
because there is that that that idea
that we're supposed to be struggling you
know van go no he struggled he didn't
make it until pretty much after he was
gone so
yeah I think that feeling shame for
finding success in what we do kind of
comes hand inand with
maturing it's a maturity process too you
know to really make it and to Define
what making it means for
you not what the record label tells you
not what a Grammy winning you know
musician tells you not what the external
tells you but what does it mean to make
it for you that looks different for
everyone I think to carry shame with
that as you start to step into that just
kind of requires a little bit of
maturity along the
way so it's okay to be like you know
what I'm putting things out there and
I'm okay with that and I'm I'm actually
proud of myself yeah the audience that
doesn't follow you they're they're
people can follow you for a time and
follow off there's always an audience
for the work that you
do I think Lady Gaga is a great example
to speak personally I was really not a
big fan of her is when she hit the scene
at first I just didn't get it and like
much later in life I've become an
audience member for her and I was like
oh I get it I was like okay um and I
like her more matured music I so I got
on her bandwagon later on I wasn't there
in the beginning that's okay for every
artist that's okay your path will take
you where you go and you're going to
meet the people you need to on your path
when you need to meet them and another
example for my life is like I loved pop
punk I loved Fallout Boy and when I was
like in middle school and high school
and when they started to get really big
I used to be like oh they sold out
they're sellouts and as an older woman
who has since worked in record labels
and worked around musicians and been on
tour with musicians I realized oh my God
this is so hard they made it good for
them wow they did that
they didn't sell out they kept
going and maybe I don't listen to their
music current day I'll revisit an old
album from time to time but the the
point
is who would who am I to hold um an
artist to some expectation that they
can't grow in their craft or in their
field or in themselves not every album
they're going to put out is going to be
amazing not everything you're going to
produce you might lose some audience
members but you're going to some too by
just staying authentic to your
path right I I always use the You2
analogy you know a beautiful day and
Gloria or two different times it seems
like in their lives and two different
emotions that you get from the song but
you know you can stay on the path with
them and realize you know life isn't so
bad or you can stay in the sort of this
activist like you know that there was a
place for that music it was it was
intense and exactly moving I like to
think of like Trent resner cuz I the
biggest n in Nails fan and how how like
emotional and suffering is that music
right and I mean I've been there and
everyone's been there right but Trent
resner through the span of his career
and his healing and his journey and what
he's been through and I like love Trent
R so I like follow him I mean he's a
film composer he's an Oscar winner he's
he runs I uh don't quote me on this but
I think he runs like nonprofit with his
wife like he's
expanded and maybe this same 9in Nails
audience from the early 9s have don't
aren't there but many of us are and
who's anyone to decide what his path and
journey should look like that's to me
what a heal the character Arc of a
healed artist is and it's not in spite
of the bad times or the suffering he had
it's because of that he was so rooted in
that but that's not all there is to him
and his music
making